all right good morning guys so we're
still doing the relatively easy workout
ten minutes kind of our formal warmup
ten minutes calisthenics and then a
meditation that's somewhere between five
and ten minutes less than ten minutes
okay
let's get started
we're back
big breath hand reaching up and back a
forward and down
yeah
behind-the-back a long fingers
bet they don't jest the forward and down
and circle the upper body
other direction
and coming back up release the hands
coming to one side keep the bottom heel
down over here if you can
toes sideways that puts on the ground
this splits all the way on the ground
back over
coming on to the knees
yeah Center elbows on the knees rocking
back and forth nice low squat here and
to the middle spread the feet
and sitting back big breath in turn it
down
I keep that spying as straight as you
can and bring the feet in the elbows
push the knees down you can spine
straight drop the chest
yeah stomach and then to the shoulders
big breath in coming up and back down
you really push those heels lipsmack
drop your knees sit back good in front
of the face
sinking it down cut the guy
other side of the guy eesh
thank you
other side some kill so if you haven't
done these with us before you can look
better earlier videos do these me
others I need yo
and pulling your fingers back y'all come
goal kill other side yeah
and she got the wrist arms
arm across the chest the other side
are behind the head
I
oh it's already getting warm in here all
right yeah okay we ready to go in this
is the last these were going to kind of
do we're gonna get into a little more
the way I work out next week okay so
hands up your hips nice good straight
spine either tuck underneath when I come
up on the balls of my feet like this
bring the knees up stand up and down
control the bees down and flatten them
that's the basic idea
arms up to the side what we're doing
that coming up on the balls of the feet
knees up stand up rotate your arms
other direction and coming down control
the knees down black and says again or
until the direction both feet means up
stand up other direction down control
the knees down black of the direction
both the feet knees up of the direction
down means flap other direction
plumpie means up other direction down
means feet
reach your arms keep them there good nut
to the side feet knees up knees
eat these up down knees feet eat means
hold this position
Circle the arms other direction other
direction other direction the direction
hold the arms halfway up so I'm about
half way right now right so trying to
keep my spine is straight possible make
sure about half way up Circle the arms
of the direction of the direction of the
direction
other direction hold your arms out all
the way up arm you're still out to the
side because arms out some whack you
with our timer I think nope
and there's solute load the arms to
count of 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
nine ten didn't she get the arms good
I'm gonna be up overhead shake her head
we're down in front of the body slowly
right here from out there
shut it down knees beat me
down me beat me down means be good take
your arms out here breath circle them in
I'm circling them both in both arms
going in down means
down knees beep mr. rotation throw it
again in e means change rotation going
out down means be change rotation be
knees up down be for nice be take
rotation be knees get on top great front
complete right slow it's in any kind of
10 there we go one two three four
this
and relax in order to shake them out
good okay so there'd be the same
position and you feel like this and take
my shoulders but rotating back as far as
I possibly can right so look you're
gonna want to share going like this
don't keep it straight spine you can
join the back as far as they go
they're not going to go straight out
like rumps through the front so just as
far as they possibly can back lifting
them up and we go down knees down knees
down knees these other direction
he means the direction down knees be
change directions the knees up change
direction now you've got spine straight
knees beep that's fine good want to
start lean forward d knees up and slow
to sit down one two
three four five six so that pressure on
seven eight nine ten down by the side
shake those shoulders out jump okay it's
you little core work on your back good
all right we do a basic rock forward and
back there do the switch next week too
but basic rock board back so I rock up
rock back
gentle like this first okay when you can
do this right so it's not a giant
struggle drop up and back like that see
if you can go a little slower right so
here's my natural pace that's pretty
naturally let me go a little slower so
this is a little artificial now we use
my spine and my muscles to slow it down
keep slowing it down until you get to
right about where you kind of can't go
anymore
okay with me I'm coming back it's pretty
slow for me pretty hard right now good
and I'm not letting them in to just take
me at a certain point when I'm here
really curly so I'm trying to be that
slo-mo version in here parking on the
come I'm going to try to avoid using a
lot of inertia do it slow record doesn't
have to be that slow but right here's
where I start failing right so that's
the speed that I start feeling it just
going where that's happening where it's
like I'm sorry to fail now that's where
you need to hang out and do about that
speed right there might be a lot faster
in the nicest way you might need to look
and use a lot more momentum
there's definitely black spots in your
spine
it's not easy to do that so just do a
few on your own now my new keyboard
select the keys your face that's another
thing yep you feel like you really
attack speed the pace up a little bit
they'll be a little easier you get a
nice little face so much comfortable for
you try this one or that really hard
base which really slow or slows you
7:15 bench already at least he's warming
up I'm undoing it Elsa I relatively soon
okay good
I'm coming it this is up I'm going to
take a risk our hands like this we're
going to rotate them in in in in in as
far as we can so we're going to lock
your elbows up push and turn against the
ground all right so I'm I see metrically
pushing right so I symmetrical pushing
pushing pushing pushing pushing pushing
pushing relax and then let it come out
when I say pushing I mean you're pushing
like like you're trying to turn your
head back out from wherever you were
right okay so are your the other
direction so brute taking my hands
around rotate my hands around
now look to undo this and we go this way
what I'm gonna do is put enough pressure
down that I can't do that and then I'm
gonna push hard to pull them out some
pushing carts it's an isometric pushing
pushing pushing pushing pushing pushing
pushing so it's a can alright now we go
the other way this time I'm not gonna go
quite as far as I can so I'm gonna go
maybe three-quarters of the way right so
all the way for me great about there as
far as they go somebody come out just a
little bit from there I'm gonna do the
same thing press your down push it out
push push push push me as far as I can
and relax good rotate him out so
bringing them out now all the way around
all the way around all the way around
good now what's he gone as far as you
can undo it just a little business it's
about three quarters for me okay and
then I'm gonna push again push I'm
pushing hard and relax good bring about
Danielle we'll need to go about half way
around for me right so it's about here
right so I can normally go about there
so halfway totally wrap up here so we're
here about the halfway position put that
pressure down and trying to turn my
hands out so I'm trying to turn my hands
this way out ready push down go one
good rest all right then we come back
again just about halfway Rex I can go
that for somebody go about half way over
it about there
Danny put that pressure in and go the
other direction go rest put my hands
down naturally where they go I'm turning
this way right so I'm still doing this
undoing action what deal on the back
exactly the way they go and then I go
the opposite I'm gonna go out some going
towards my pinkie side enough pressure
they can't turn a move ready go good my
hand that same position does someone go
in so I'm gonna turn in like this hey
ready go that's just isometric exercise
of putting the arm into a position then
we're working our muscles hard as we can
to get it out of that position I spent
you to a really good way to build
strength the only problem with
isometrics is they only work the
strength will only be in that one range
so if I put my hand here and push you
out really only working with my muscles
in this configuration so I want to get a
number of those right it's not quite
it's critical with this rotation that it
is with something like your shoulders so
you can do isometric exercises with your
arm too like so say I put a chair here
underneath my hand and then I push down
as hard as I can on the chair I'll only
be isometrically only being a lot of
strength right in this range so I want
to change the different ranges as I
worked at isometrics not quite as
critical the way we were working it
right now because in truth you're really
working that same group no matter where
you're on the rotation but it gives us a
nice set to kind of work through which
is good okay meditation guys okay so
observational meditation again I might
do a guided in the near future we'll see
because I've been doing this
observational I use it because this is
what I use for myself all the time it
it's the hardest for me in most ways
because
there's lots of little cool tricks and
meditation techniques you can use and
and sometimes neat fun stuff you can
explore in meditation which is cool but
to me the strictest hardest kind is just
observational meditation like this
where's you know I just stay present and
try not to follow down my own rabbit
holes or overly investigate the birds
outside or whatever it is that my mind
slashed onto at the moment and instead
just let it go and go on so that's the
idea okay so the clock we got set here
for about seven and a half minutes so
we're gonna go just a little past the
clocks we're gonna sit for at least
seven and a half minutes three bells in
three bells out
[Music]
okay guys that's our workout meditation
for me today I had a hard time going
down rabbit holes so that's just the way
it is sometimes your mind has a hard
time focusing let go of it though you
know so don't beat yourself up about it
we have a tendency like we're our own
dad or something you know tell us like
you need to think about what you did and
the truth is that's just generally
making you less functional human being
worrying about the mistakes you made
right so it's time to be analytical
medication it's not that time so if
you're catching yourself going down a
rabbit hole
just stop the rabbit hole don't go down
it any more don't have any commentary
about it don't tell yourself you're a
batboy rag like everything's cool all
right
that is it we will see you next Tuesday
I might be outside I think the weather's
gonna get a little cooler so probably
inside for a little little while longer
we're gonna change the workouts a little
bit let's show you kinda a little more
how I worked out which is a little more
organic in nature all right that's it
take care guys see you next time